coutet en attend un débat qui se voudra
constructif nous souhaitons nous l'avons
dit la commission des lois ce matin
confirmer notre volonté de voter le pass
vaccinale nous prenons note que la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale mais l'assemblée nationale
elle même a repris un certain nombre
d'éléments importants que nous avions
négocié
avant la commission mixte paritaire où
la commission mixte paritaire qui
malheureusement n'a pas abouti et nous
avons invité vous tendre un peu la main
là à vous de jouer ce côté on aurait pu
si c'est ça on aurait pu gagner beaucoup
de temps dès jeudi soir était réglé ce
n'est pas ça il en reste néanmoins deux
sujets sur lequel au moins deux sujets
sur lequel nous discutons c'est celui
des contrôles effectués par les
restaurateurs et celui des amendes aux
entreprises pour lequel nous avons une
divergence de fond faut expliquer parce
que les députés ont rétabli la
possibilité
donnée aux restaurateurs aux cafetiers
de faire des contrôles d'identité aux
détenteurs de pass vaccinale vous vous
dites c'est hors de question je rappelle
que le sénat a voté à la quasi-unanimité
puis 303 voix pour la suppression de cet
article nous avons donc une position
large ferme et solide c'est une ligne
rouge donc pour nous c'est une ligne
rouge pourquoi c'est dangereux selon
vous parce qu'on va pas transformer nos
restaurateurs en policier et puis on
sait en réalité au delà de tout ça on
sait qu'ils ne le font pas ou qui ne
pourront pas le faire interrogés tout
simplement les restaurateurs ce qui vous
pouvait aller en ce moment ils vont vous
répondre très très directement donc
c'est une mesure inutile faisons un
pouce et un peu confiance aux gens
malgré tout et c'est une mesure qui nous
paraît pas opérante en tous les cas et
sur les amendes aux entreprises là aussi
pour vous hors de question de mettre des
amendes aux entreprises récalcitrantes
au télétravail c'est une procédure
nouvelle qui nous est proposé c'est
prévu aujourd'hui une difficulté aurait
rencontré éventuellement un employeurs
récalcitrants qui ne mettraient en
danger ses salariés pourra faire l'objet
de poursuites devant le tribunal
correctionnel c'est la loi il suffit je
le pense sincèrement que garde des
sceaux par voie de circulaire
sensibilise les procureurs sur le sujet
pour que la réponse pénale puisse
arriver rapidement en cas de difficultés
constatées là aussi sur espérons quand
même que je ne sois pas les cas les plus
nombreux est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
une adoption conforme de ce texte non si
je vous entends aujourd'hui n'y aura pas
d'adoption conforme c'est-à-dire dans
les mêmes termes que les termes adoptés
par les députés hier soir l'assemblée si
la commission déplore proposera
d'adopter largement le texte voté par
l'assemblée nationale modulo les deux
points que je viens d'évoquer sur lequel
nous reviendrons la position du sénat
donc c'est eu ce n'est pas un conte
forme totalement conforme très
majoritaire peut-être un mot de
l'imbroglio autour précisément de cette
cmp de cette commission mixte paritaire
jeudi vous y étiez qu'est ce qui s'est
passé précisément fera pas revenir sur
un événement malheureux
mais nous avions un accord avec nos
collègues députés on a beaucoup
travaillé et nous avions cet accord nous
attendions les documents rédigés mais
sur lequel on s'était mis d'accord et
nous allions rentrer en sciant à nouveau
en commission mixte paritaire pour
proposer notre accord à l'ensemble des
collègues et c'est à ce moment là que
mon homologue de l'assemblée nationale
prenant prétexte de devenir de ce tweet
à a suspendu immédiatement la séance et
a mis fin à la réunion vous dites
prétexte oui parce que je pense que
c'est c'est pas le sujet c'était
surexposition drac surréaction nous le
parlement était engagé le parlement
avait un accord
l'enjeu c'était aussi d'aller vite
c'était aussi le souhait du gouvernement
résultat des courses l'accord n'a pas
été entérinée alors qu'il existait
résultat nous avons perdu du temps nous
car du temps et nous n'aurons pas le
texte dans les délais qui étaient
voulues par le gouvernement mais pour le
coup ce sera pas de la faute du sénat
pour une droite ailleurs il a commis une
faute avec ce tweet le président du
groupe a l'air ici au sénat l'a dit que
c'était malheureux il est allé trop vite
bon c'est malheureux tournons la page
c'est fait un se sert à rien de ces
faits avance on sait d'après midi votons
ce que nous avons voté ce matin à la
commission des lois et puis le
l'assemblée nationale demain siégera et
elle vous prendra position sur les deux
points que nous allons lui soumettre en
faute petite dernière question monsieur
lui fait les députés ont supprimé la
possibilité de fixer des jauges
proportionnelle dans les stades et les
salles de spectacle à ce que le sénat va
revenir là dessus bah le débat va
s'ouvrir tout à l'heure c'est une
question qui est posée eh bien on va
suivre ça avec attention merci beaucoup
monsieur c
[Musique]